hey guys how's it going matt from code
tech tutorials i want to talk
about how to actually make successful
stuff whether it be software well this
is mainly software actually this is
going to be kind of pigeon holed into
how to
make your software viable for a long
period of time
and this is really all taken from jim
keller's take on this
as you can see he has a long list of
credentials
that make him highly qualified to give
such advice
so yeah he's worked for uh apple tesla
amd
okay so jim was on the lex podcast
and he was he was basically saying most
people don't think simple enough but
that's not the part i want to take away
from this because
he says something really important here
about
managing your software and keeping it
viable and fast enough for the modern
era and this is something
that i have personally experienced which
i'll show you a little later it's kind
of a small example but it's something
that
where i kind of had this experience too
and
hearing this was like yeah that happened
to me too
okay i don't want to like steal too much
of this but i think it's important that
we watch from
this section for just just about a
minute
and hopefully it doesn't get claimed or
something but this kind of
builds upon the rest of the context i
want to show you so let's just take a
moment
and listen so common practices you build
a computer and then when somebody says i
want to make it 10
faster you'll go in and say all right i
need to make this buffer bigger
and maybe i'll add an ad unit or you
know i have this thing that's three
instructions wide i'm going to make it
four instructions wide
and what you see is each piece gets
incrementally more
complicated right and then at some point
you hit this
limit okay that's important eventually
you hit a limit with things you can add
some kind of fundamental limit based on
the design you went with
way back when when you first made the
stuff or whatever it is
so i'm going to hit play here and just
just listen to this next part
and then somebody else will look at it
and say well actually the way you
divided the problem up
and the way the different features are
interacting is limiting you and it has
to be rethought rewritten
there we go has to be rethought and
rewritten
i'm running into this right now with the
game engine i've been
working on it's it's convoluted it's
confusing i'm having trouble
adding features and i need to rewrite it
that's not even the example i was
talking about just a moment ago i have a
real one of something that's
more finished that i i did i'll show you
but
this is highly relatable to what i'm
doing so i've been working on this game
engine for like two years and i hit a
wall recently of just
doesn't seem to work correctly anymore
so yes i will be rewriting it on stream
so
check out my stream it's either going to
be twitch.tv
pro 17128 or i might just change it back
to my name
so then you refactor and rewrite it and
what people commonly find
is the rewrite is not only faster but
half is complicated
yes half is complicated and faster
so it's a win-win right okay there's
there's a little more to this
okay jumping forward a little bit to
just throw the hole out
the whole thing out this is where i'm on
one end of it
every three to five years which end are
you on three to five years okay
this is about right for my game engine
because it's it's been about three years
so i think i think it's time
um you know i'm just finding a way to
relate to me personally but for you
you might be working on something you've
been working on for three to five years
hit a wall or it's a hard advance
anymore
you might be in the same boat where you
just need to start over and rewrite
simplify it wait rewrite more often
right and three to five years is so if
you want to really make a lot of
progress on computer architecture every
five years you should do one from
scratch
it's for the greater good this is where
he mentions kind of what the industry
tends to do which is rewrite every 10
years
there's a tendency to rewrite it every
you know 10 years and it really should
be every 5.
that's a lot of years if i think about
this in terms of that
game engine i'm writing i would sit and
dwell on this
silly little problems i'm having that
hold me back for another
seven years of my life
if i didn't just sit down and rewrite it
that's big that's okay so it sounds
you know it sounds intimidating to start
over but it's gonna save you seven years
it's kind of a big deal you know all
right let's continue you're saying
you're an outlier in that sense in the
more often we write more often well and
here isn't that scary
yeah of course well scary to who
to uh everybody involved it's less scary
than you think from someone who's done
it
before on a small scale i don't
obviously make microprocessors or os's
or anything but
but just on the small scale that i have
done this yeah it was scary
it was really hard to throw out my old
code but
it was definitely worth it because well
i'll show you in a minute after we're
done with watching this
because like you said repeating the
recipe is efficient
companies want to make money
very good into the diminishing return
curves
i think steve jobs said this right so
every you have a project
and you start here and it goes up and
they have diminishing return
and to get to the next level you have to
do a new one and the initial starting
point
will be lower than the the old
optimization point
but it'll get higher there you go
okay so you have a program or software
you're writing
and say this is the starting point and
you make it it's going pretty good it
goes okay eventually
you hit a limit and boom all you this is
where you're doing
tiny tiny optimizations it might get a
tiny bit better here and there
but there's no more of this big initial
ramp that big initial ramp is over
and so this is your product it's
successful it's doing well
but eventually technology advances and
it kind of becomes
obsolete it's not really good enough
anymore
and uh you're but you're a big
successful company uh
and you you got to maintain it so so
what do you do you just keep working on
it and trying to trying to get a little
higher and try
just trying really hard putting in tons
of work for every little increase
or what you do is you just go
all right well we'll leave a team to you
know fix bugs or whatever
over here we'll also have someone just
start a rewrite
or maybe this you're just so a person so
what you do is you say all right let's
scrap
all this let's redo it let's make the
logic better simplify it
so say you start you start here
the starting point it's not as good as
your old project is
i guess i'm kind of making this uh time
down here i'll just call it t
and this is like uh usefulness i guess
useful to scale so you start down here
but what happens is with this new logic
in this better
setup you get you get the nice ramp up
again
what happens is you end up quite quickly
above the old optimized level but you
did have to
take a step back before you could take
two steps forward
and what you do is you do that again
basically you get to
a higher point than you ever would if
you would have never
gotten here maybe maybe like 30 years of
optimizations eventually the slow slow
climb you know but you could do it real
quickly
by just doing the rewrite and boom
getting that big scale up i have
i've definitely experienced this too and
uh
maybe we'll watch just a little bit more
and then i'll show you the examples of
my projects here
okay back back to the clip you know
people with a quarter by quarter
business objective are terrified about
changing everything yeah okay uh i don't
know if he gets into this here but
there's
it's uh i forget where i saw this but
it's basically the marketing team once
you have a successful project
uh product the marketing team wants to
keep pushing it
and they don't want to start over
because they can't say
right off the bat that it's better so i
guess you have
like you know a hidden project behind
the scenes where you're redoing it and
you just don't let the marketing team
know or something because all they care
about is getting the sales they don't
even they might not even know how this
stuff works but
all right let's watch a little bit more
and people who are trying to run
a business or build a computer for a
long-term objective
know that the short-term limitations
blocked them from the long-term success
leaders of companies that had really
good long-term success
every time they saw that they had to
redo something they did
and so somebody has this okay and then
he says it again
all the companies that have had good
long-term success when they saw they
needed to redo something
they simply just did
all right i'll i'll show you my project
i'll show you what i'm talking about
it's going to be hard to show because i
don't have the old stuff but i'll still
show it anyway
okay it's it's mainly this piece of
software i started writing this
i had only been coding for about a year
with c
plus plus when i started writing this in
c plus plus so it's
it's not the greatest but i experienced
exactly what he said there i i tried to
you know okay i'll give you a little bit
of a backstory about this it's called d
empower it's just a little dungeons and
dragons terminal app for uh dungeon
masters to
help assist you when you're dming and
basically make your game a whole bun
a whole lot faster so you don't have to
go digging through books for every
little thing and
come up with ideas on the fly uh that
might
be hard to figure out all right you see
it only has two stars
it did at one point have like 50 some
and then i made it private for a while
because i was kind of
scared of wizards of the coast suing me
or something because this kind of
is their intellectual property in a lot
of ways i'm using a lot of stuff from
their books but i don't
i don't know if it matters i don't make
any money off of it it's just an open
source
thing but they have some product where
you can sign on and get all their stuff
but
in my mind their product is terrible
actually i really can't stand their uh
product i'll show you i guess
all right yeah it's this one d d beyond
this did not exist when i started making
my piece of software dnd and beyond was
not a thing when i first started writing
dm power
so they came out with this like when i
was
mostly done my software so i had no idea
that they were
basically doing it this is basically the
same thing except theirs is
well obviously it's more robust but also
you always have to be connected to the
internet it crashes all the time their
web page
rarely loads correctly it's it's pretty
terrible even
like i played with a new group of d d
players and they all use d and d beyond
and like half of the session was them
complaining about d
and d beyond not working and i was just
like ah
and so i just use my software instead
and
it i don't know it's fine it's a little
con you know it's not as like user
friendly you got to be used to like
terminal stuff i guess
and be happy with that but you know d
and d beyond for like
uh ipads and touch screen stuffs really
nice for that but it also costs money of
course
yeah in my experience it's not very it's
pretty buggy and crappy
i i wasn't a fan i didn't like it it was
really sad to see a bunch of people
paying for it and buying it and just
crashing on them so anyway
dm power i wrote this many
many times over i started over so many
times i was trying to figure stuff out i
must have had like
20 versions of this that i scrapped
before i got to this one that's
actually up here that works correctly
and works good
i've had a few contributors help out
with it um
i'm sure it would be a lot bigger if i
didn't private it for like half a year
and lose all its
reputation basically but it's starting
to build something up slowly it's got
two already
but yeah at one point it did i think
this actually got me a job at one point
because i interviewed for a company and
they looked at my github and saw i had a
c plus program with a bunch of stars and
they were like oh okay yeah
yeah it was basically an auto hire it
was pretty cool
but yeah then i then i got scared got
frightened
from wizards of the coast someone left a
comment that said you can't do that or
something and i was trying to look into
it and figure it out
eventually i just said ah screw it i'll
just put it back up what's the worst
that could happen
they could send me a takedown notice
okay it's a loss to the community
not really to me i'll just maintain it
privately oh i don't know maybe it'll go
good maybe they'll say like hey we'll
make you an offer for this or something
i don't know
i don't really advertise this normally
or anything so it's kind of just found
naturally if it does get
found so i have all these old versions
of times i've
updated it i haven't updated it since
mid last year
usually when there's updates to the game
or a new book comes out i would update
it and add all the new stuff
i would add all the new classes there
was a giant update here where i added in
all these classes and
races or just races i guess i really
like it i use it all the time when i'm
playing because it's just so much faster
than looking up stuff in the books and
looking up charts this just has
everything
built in and it's really fast because c
plus plus
yeah but the point is the first couple
the first version of this
totally scrapped second version scrap
third version
scrap fourth version i was kind of happy
with it was going okay but then i hit
limits of stuff where i was doing things
in weird ways
and i couldn't continue the software the
way i wanted i couldn't get i can't
remember i couldn't get like subclasses
working right or there was something
that i could get working right
so i completely scrapped it and started
over yet again and i
experienced i experienced
this goodness is strolling so terrible i
experienced this
where i had the you know a version that
would go like this
and when i would hit limits and could it
had a really hard time improving
so i just have to start over and lose
everything and do it again
and do it again eventually i got to the
point where i was happy
and i'm not rewriting it but as of right
now
i'm pretty sure this needs rewritten
again because it kind of has hit a limit
it's very hard to update it's a lot of
code to update to add classes and stuff
so there's probably a better way of
doing it now i'm sure there is
i started writing this when i i had only
been coding c plus plus for about a year
and i just wanted a project to work on
because school wasn't
cutting it like i would get you know get
labs and stuff for computer science but
like it wasn't enough i would have this
whole summer off
where i had literally no coding to do
unless i came up with my own thing and
that's where this came in i was playing
dnd with some friends and i was like hey
i could just write some software to save
as much time because we're just digging
through books wasting like 10 minutes
here and there
and so i did i don't know i did have a
group i played with where we all used
this and it was
it was a good time it was a really good
time i might publish that campaign one
day but
who knows i guess that's my big example
is i actually experienced this
many years ago right here
on this piece of software so i just i
just thought that was cool and now i'm
experiencing again
uh yeah i'm really railing this i'm
really railing this in
pretty hard i know you guys have got it
a long time ago and probably clicked
away but for those of you that are still
here
i i appreciate you and uh
i guess that's pretty much the the end
of it and
and the whole takeaway is if you're
struggling with your piece of software
and having a really
hard time getting it any further it's
probably time to just rewrite the thing
all right thanks for watching i
really appreciate you guys you can
support me on patreon if you want to see
more of these videos please let me know
your feedback in the comments
and i don't know i'll see i'll see you
in the next video or maybe on twitch
or uh i don't know maybe maybe on the
discord it's a private discord you have
to join patreon to get on there but i do
respond very quickly to anything you ask
me and i'll also
review your stuff if you have anything
you want me to review
just sign up for any of the tiers on on
patreon and send me a link and
and if i might if it's really
interesting i might even ask if it's
okay if i make a video about it so
i don't know holler matt out peace guys